The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Our goal for
today is to basically analyze
this simple model to death.
So we're first going
to try to understand
the deterministic behavior
of this model gene
expression, where we just
get transcription of mRNA,
and then translation of protein.
And after we think we
understand the mean behavior,
the deterministic
dynamics, then we
will try to understand
just stochastic behavior
in this model.
So we're going to
try to understand
what's the distribution
of mRNA in a cell
in this simple situation.
What's the distribution
of protein?
What's going to be
the bursting behavior?
Everything you can
possibly think of
to ask about this
model, we will hopefully
have asked by the
end of today's class.
This simple model
of gene expression,
as was indicated in
the review, is perhaps
a reasonable description
of gene expression
in bacteria, when the gene
is in some active state.
So there's no repressor,
for example, bound.
Although maybe even
in the presence
of a repressor, if it's
binding and unbinding,
maybe you still end up getting
some sort of renormalization
that looks like this.
But this is first order,
a reasonable description
of gene expression in bacteria.
And it's the model
that was basically
used in the Sunney Xie
paper that we talked about
on Tuesday.
And hopefully this
model will allow
us to think a little bit
more deeply about the data
that they obtained
in that paper.
As always, we want to
start by understanding
the basic aspects of the model.
So what we're going
to do, is we're
going to go through
a series of questions
of increasing difficulty.
And in some of
them, we are indeed,
the answers will end up being
something divided by something.
In which case you take
advantage of your cards,
and illustrate that by putting
something on top, something
below.
But just first in this model,
what is the unit of time?
So if I say t is equal to
1, or delta t is equal to 1,
what am I referring to?
So we're not use the cards.
But in particular, the question
is, is delta t equal to 1,
is that a cell
cycle necessarily?
Yes or no, ready,
three, two, one.
Well I guess now maybe I've
complicated things by-- well,
this was really going to be
relevant for the later ones.
All right.
Now I've totally confused you.
But can somebody offer
why it may or may not
be-- how do we think about the
unit of time in this model?
AUDIENCE: Usually
the lifetime of one
of the species [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK so indeed, what we often do
in these non-dimensionalized
models is we set
something equal to 1.
Have we set anything
equal to 1 here?
No.
So in principle,
we've said there's
some degradation rate of
the mRNA, some degradation
rate of the protein.
And in general, those will be
given in some units involving
seconds or minutes or hours.
So in general, so
at this stage, we
have not yet-- we
have not actually
gotten to this sort of
non-dimensionalized version
of any model.
So in this case this is
going to be something
like a seconds, or
minutes, or hours,
whatever units we use for
those degradation rates.
So we have not done anything
where it's the cell generation
time, or the protein lifetime,
mRNA lifetime, or anything
like that.
Here everybody happy with
this statement so far?
So we'll go ahead and vote here.
So we're going to do
some A, B, C, D's.
And you can always
combine anything you want.
So we'll go ahead
and say this is
the synthesis rate of the mRNA.
This is the degradation rate
for the mRNA, the synthesis
rate for the protein,
the degradation
rate for the protein.
And if you're just confused,
you can just do this.
But in general, for any of the
questions we're going to do,
you can do some
combination of these guys
by putting things in
numerator and denominator.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Calculate the
population of the cells
that were hidden?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Question is, if you just
look at the cell population,
and you find it's
growing exponentially,
the question is what is
going to be that rate
of exponential growth.
Have I done something
wrong already?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK.
But I am going to say
that now for this we're
going to assume that
the protein is stable.
So it's not actually degraded.
This is to remind you of what
we read about in chapter one,
maybe of Uri's book,
maybe chapter two.
I'll give you 10 seconds
to think about this.
Do you need more time?
All right, Ready,
three, two, one.
OK.
We got a bunch of C's and a
bunch of D's and some E's.
All right.
So the E's are going to argue
with me, presumably rather than
a neighbor.
OK.
I think that there
are enough people that
are disagreeing on this to
maybe go ahead, and turn.
You should be able
to find somebody
that disagrees with you.
The distribution was a
bit patchy, unfortunately.
Did you guys-- you guys are
worried that you're not going
to be able to find somebody.
OK.
Fine, fine.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if the
protein is stable, ah,
so the mRNA may not be stable?
PROFESSOR: The mRNA
may not be stable.
AUDIENCE: Ah, OK.
That makes sense.
PROFESSOR: And in general
which one typically
has a longer lifetime?
AUDIENCE: Proteins.
PROFESSOR: Proteins typically
have a longer lifetime.
Right.
So mRNA are actively
degraded, typically.
They're also just kind of
less stable intrinsically.
But what we're going
to assume for now
is that we're working
with stable proteins.
In which case the growth
rate of the population
will just be this
effective degradation
rate of the protein.
So in this model,
even if we say there's
no active degradation
of the protein,
still there's going to be some
effective degradation that's
due to dilution.
So we can say
effective, if you like.
So the rate of exponential
growth of the population
will be equal to this
effective degradation
rate for the protein,
if it's stable.
AUDIENCE: So you're talking
about the population
of the protein?
PROFESSOR: No.
The growth rate of
the cell population.
So this is if we go
in there, and you
go into your spectrophotometer.
And you measure population--
numbers in function of time
is growing exponentially.
It'll grow exponentially
with this rate.
Because this is what's
causing the dilution.
In some ways if you
stop making the protein,
and you double the number
of cells, and that means
the concentration of
the protein in each cell
has to go down by
a factor of two.
So that's the statement.
Are there any questions about
why I'm making this argument?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What was the relevance
of the protein being stable?
PROFESSOR: All right.
So the relevance of
the protein being
stable, because this is in
general, this delta, this
is the effective rate.
This is going to be equal to the
growth rate of the population.
So you might call
it gamma growth
plus the actual degradation.
I don't want to use
the same, but I'll just
say plus the degradation rate.
And this is a true physical
degradation, true degradation
rate of the protein.
So if it's stable, then we
say that this thing is zero.
So when we say
stable protein, it
means there's no
degradation of the protein.
So this physical
degradation rate is zero.
And then the effective
degradation rate of the protein
is just equal to the growth
rate of the population.
AUDIENCE: OK, so no degradation
means stable, basically?
PROFESSOR: Yes, sorry, yeah.
Any other questions about
what I mean by this?
So now what we want to do is
ask a few other quantities
about this model.
So for example, what will be
the number of mRNA per cell?
And this is always
going to be the mean.
I'll give you 20 seconds.
In this model what is the
mean number of mRNA per cell?
All right.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
And we have let's say
a majority of the group
is saying it's A over B, which
corresponds to the synthesis
rate of the mRNA divided
by the degradation.
Some people are this one?
Yes, so this is
indeed, synthesis rate
divided by the degradation rate.
Now this is saying
that what happens later
doesn't really matter,
for the mean mRNA number.
Because it's just that it's
going to be made at some rate.
Its lifetime is given
by 1 over delta m.
Now this thing, of course,
is again as always,
the effective degradation rate.
So it's the sum of the sort
of physical degradation rate,
plus this dilution
due to growth.
But in general, the
true degradation,
the physical degradation is much
faster than the cell division
rate.
So this is very close
to actually just
the physical degradation rate.
But in any case, it's
just delta m, regardless.
Are there any questions about
why this is the way it is?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does it matter
whether it's only physical?
Because wouldn't it be
the same if it were--
PROFESSOR: It doesn't matter
that it's only-- exactly.
That's what I was trying to say.
So the way that
this is written, it
doesn't matter whether the--
this is the answer regardless
of whether the
physical degradation
rate is much larger than
the growth rate or not.
Yeah.
All right.
What is this protein
molecules per mRNA?
How many protein molecules
are made from each mRNA?
Protein produced-- Do
you need more time?
Remember.
This is again, the
mean number of proteins
produced from a single
mRNA or each mRNA.
Let's go ahead and vote,
so I can see where we are.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK.
So we have, I'd say,
so at least a majority
are saying it's going
to be C over B Now.
All right.
So this is interesting.
So this is saying that
really what's happening
is that there's a
competition once you
make an mRNA that the proteins
are going to be getting
fired off at some rate.
But eventually it's
going to be degraded.
It's a competition
between those two rates
that determines basically
how many proteins,
how many times do you fire
off a protein before you
get degraded.
Any questions about that logic?
AUDIENCE: Can you please just
repeat that one more time?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Right, so what we're assuming
is that OK, an mRNA is produced.
And that's already happened.
So it doesn't matter
what Sm is anymore.
So now we have an mRNA.
Eventually this mRNA
will be degraded.
But before that happens,
we want to know, basically
how many proteins do
we expect to be made.
Now if Sp and delta m
are the same that means
you kind of expect one
protein to be made on average,
before it's degraded.
Or if Sp we're twice
delta m, then you
would get two proteins made
before it was degraded.
Now this is a mean statement.
We're about to start
thinking-- in 10 minutes,
we'll think about
this distribution.
And so we have to be careful.
But in terms of mean
behavior, this thing is true.
AUDIENCE: So is this
different than it
has been for the number of
proteins per mRNA in the cell?
PROFESSOR: Is this
different from the number
of proteins in the cell?
AUDIENCE: Number of proteins
per mRNA in the cell.
Because then you will have to
do the protein concentration
over mRNA concentration.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Right.
So this is not the same thing
as asking about the ratio
of the number of proteins.
And we can calculate
that as well.
Yeah these are different.
This is the number
of protein molecules
produced from each mRNA.
So this is just talking
about production.
Because indeed, the
degradation rates
are going to be different.
So then we can see what
that ends up being.
Any other questions about
why this one is what it is?
How about the number of mRNA
produced per cell cycle?
And for now we're going to
ignore factors of log two.
Do you need more time?
So another 10 seconds.
AUDIENCE: Produced
but not degraded?
PROFESSOR: Produced, yes.
We're just talking
about production.
Because we've already calculated
a number of mRNA in the cell.
But now we want to know
the mean number produced.
For example, this is the
same as the mean number
of protein bursts observed
in Sunney Xie's paper.
But this is just the number of
mRNA produced per cell cycle.
All right.
Let's see where we are.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
So we've got lots
of A's over D's.
That's sounds nice.
So this is going to be
some synthesis rate.
But now the relevant
thing is this delta p.
Because that's the
cell division rate.
So it's barring
issues of log two,
it's approximately
the synthesis rate
of the mRNA divided by delta p.
Because this is the
growth rate of population.
Cell generation time
is log two off of that.
Are there any questions
about that statement?
All right, so this
is the mean number.
Now from the paper, we know
how this thing is distributed.
We should probably-- we're going
to use a bunch of distributions
over the next couple.
So we can-- we like
exponential distributions.
We like geometric distributions.
We like Poisson.
We like Gaussian.
And we like gamma.
These are various
probability distributions.
The question is, how is
it that now, not the mean,
but how is the number
of mRNA produced
per cell cycle distributed.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
We've got some-- this side
of the rooms a little bit
slower, maybe.
But that's OK.
So maybe some people are not
confident of this statement.
OK.
So this one ends
up being Poisson.
So this is indeed how
the number of-- this
is number mRNA per cycle.
Now this is-- so
Poisson, in general,
that's what you get if there's
some probability per unit time
that something's
going to happen,
and you want to know how many of
them happen in some finite time
period.
That's basically the
definition of a Poisson.
And this is, if you recall,
this is what we talked about
on Tuesday.
The probability observe n,
it's given by this mean number.
So if lambda is
the mean, then we
get lambda to the
n, over n factorial,
e to the minus lambda.
If you go ahead and
calculate the mean of this,
you indeed get lambda.
So lambda is equal to the
mean, which in this case
was around, well in the
case of Sunney's paper,
does anybody remember
what that roughly was?
It was around one.
Now what about this other one?
So we also have
another mRNA problem,
which is that we calculated the
mean number of mRNA per cell.
If you look at a cell,
the mean number is this.
But what's the
probability distribution
of the number of mRNA per cell?
So we probably-- I'm trying
think it-- you probably
don't yet know this answer.
This ends up also being Poisson.
We're going to
calculate this in a bit.
But this is very
confusing somehow.
That both this thing and
this thing, are Poisson.
But they're not
the same Poisson,
in the sense they have
different lambdas.
Which one is going to be larger?
This one or this one?
The bottom one, right?
And that's because delta m
is much larger than delta p,
typically.
So indeed, if you ask, in
Sunney's paper, for example,
there was just over one mRNA
produced per cell cycle.
But the mean number of mRNA
might have been 1/30th of that.
Because the degradation rate
was just 1 and 1/2 minutes.
What that's saying is that
in a typical situation
you would not see an mRNA
in a cell in that condition.
We're going to calculate
this in a moment.
So don't worry if you don't
see why it's a Poisson.
But don't get confused.
There are two
different distributions
that arise from the mRNA in
the cell or in the cell cycle.
And they're different Poissons.
And I think that-- I mean I'm
sure that in some deep sense
there's a reason that
they're the same.
But it's somehow not
immediately obvious.
So there was another one that
we might have wanted to do,
which is the mean number
of proteins in each cell.
Now this one is a bit harder.
And this one is going to take
full advantage of the cards
that you have in front of you.
So be prepared.
I'm going to give
you 30 seconds.
Because this one
you might-- well
you might need a
little bit more time.
AUDIENCE: This is hard.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Although I think that
it's useful to see that
it can be a bit tricky.
Because this really is the
simplest possible model.
We're going to talk
about some models that
get to be horribly complicated.
And so it's useful
to just make sure
you can nail down the
intuition on this model.
All right.
Do you need more time?
It's OK if this is escaping
you at this moment.
Why don't we go and
see where we are?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
So you know all the
naysayers on the cards,
now that you've
done this, you feel
like it's an amazing system.
So it's AC over DB.
So the two, the product
of the synthesis rates
divided by the product
of degradation rates.
So what we have is
the synthesis rate
for the mRNA divided by the
degradation rate for the mRNA.
Synthesis rate for the proteins
divided by the degradation rate
for the proteins.
Can somebody give us
a verbal explanation
for why this might have
been, or why this is?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It's
the same reasoning
as the number of mRNA per cell.
But instead of just a
basel-- like a synthesis rate
doesn't depend on
the concentration.
You're just multiplying
the synthesis rate
by the number of mRNA.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's great.
OK.
So what you're saying is that
this thing here was indeed,
we calculate that was the mean
number of mRNA in the cell.
If you just start
with something,
and you have a production
and degradation rate.
OK.
Well that means that if you had
one mRNA, then indeed that's
what the concentration would be,
is this Sp divided by delta p.
But now we-- well we multiply
that by the number of mRNA,
and then we are set.
All right.
Now another question.
We have a distribution,
or a mean protein--
wait sorry, mean number.
We have the mean number
of protein produced
from each mRNA, is something.
And the question is, is this the
most likely number of proteins
to observe.
Is the distribution
here, now this is a mean,
but now we want
to start thinking
about the probabilistic
stochastic elements.
Is this the most likely, is
it like the number of proteins
observed from an mRNA?
The question is, is
this most likely.
By which I mean is the
probability distribution
peaked here.
So we're going to do an A
as a yes, and B is a no.
Does everybody understand the
question I'm trying to ask?
So an mRNA is here.
There's going to be some
proteins made from it.
This is the mean.
What I want to know is, is
that we should somehow expect?
In a sense, is the distribution
peaked, the probability
distribution peaked
around this value?
And C is-- do I want
to do a depends?
Well you can always argue after.
Do you need more time?
AUDIENCE: Is this,
you're saying,
is this the most likely
number of proteins?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What I'm wondering
is the mode there?
AUDIENCE: Right.
But only for this quantity?
PROFESSOR: Only yeah.
So now we're not
doing means anymore.
We want to know if the
probability distribution
of the protein
produced from each mRNA
is the mode around this.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
We got a lot of
no's, but some yeses.
So this is actually
going to be a no.
And this was because the
probability distribution.
The question is, what is
the probability distribution
for the number of proteins
produced from each mRNA.
It's going to be one of these.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
All right.
So we've got some difference.
But I'd say that
most of the group
is saying it's
going to be A or B.
And indeed these are almost
the same distributions.
What's the difference
between them?
AUDIENCE: One's discrete--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this guy's discrete.
This guy is continuous.
Right.
Indeed when we're taking
about the numbers,
then we should get--
it's a geometric.
But often we're kind of a little
bit loose about these things.
So it's not a disaster
if you said exponential.
But the key thing is
that the distribution
looks something like--
so now I've certainly
drawn it as an exponential.
This is the probability
of n as a function of n.
Of course, the geometric
thing it looks--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So why should we expect
that distribution?
PROFESSOR: Why should we
expect the distribution?
So one answer is
that because that's
what you read on Tuesday.
But let's go ahead and--
yes, but let's go ahead
and calculate it.
That's useful.
The way to think about
this, in some ways,
there's another way
to write this perhaps.
Which is that imagine
you have an mRNA.
Now at some rate it's
going to be degraded.
And maybe we'll keep the
degradation rate down,
just for-- so there's
a degradation rate.
But then if you'd like, we
could draw it like this.
Where this is the synthesis
rate for a protein.
And out pops a protein.
And so the idea is that is
here we're in some state where,
OK, here we have an mRNA.
Here's the state where
we don't have an mRNA.
Now this is the competition
between those two rates
that I was telling you about.
There is some degradation
rate for the mRNA.
Or there's a synthesis rate
where we go around this loop.
If we come around this
loop, we come back
to the state with an mRNA.
There still is an mRNA intact.
Just out pops a protein.
So then what we
want to do, is we
want to think about what's
the number of proteins
that we expect,
not just the mean,
but the actual distribution.
So it's useful in
these situations
to define some probability
rho, which is the probability
you actually, if
you're here, it's
the probability that you
produce one protein at least.
The question is, which
path do you take initially.
Well that's just
given by the ratios.
So there's the rate that we
take this circular path divided
by the sum of these
two other rates.
And then what we can
do is we can ask, well
what is the probability that
0 proteins are produced,
probability that we get 0.
Well if we take
this path initially,
will we have 0 proteins?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Right, so this
probability is indeed
simply equal to the probability
that we do this first, which
is 1 minus rho.
Now what's the probably
that we get 1 protein?
Well, only 1?
That's equal to the probability
that we first take this path,
and then we take this path.
Well we can multiply
those probabilities.
Because we first take
the circular path
to make a protein.
And then we take the
degradation path.
Well what's the
probability we get 2?
Well that's just that we
come around here once,
twice, and then degrade.
Now if you're not
seeing a pattern here,
then we're in trouble.
So this says the
probability of n
will then just be equal to
rho to the n, 1 minus rho.
And indeed, it's
always useful in order
to warm up your
probability muscles,
to check to make sure that this
is a normalized probability
distribution.
So sum over all possible
ends indeed goes to 1.
And that's just because the sum
over a bunch of rho to the n's
is equal to 1 divided by 1 minus
rho, which is the term there.
And that goes to 1.
AUDIENCE: So this is making
a pretty strong assumption
that they're all independent?
PROFESSOR: Yep, yep.
Yep.
This is assuming that if you've
gone around once, you return.
But I've come back to
the original state.
AUDIENCE: But do
mRNAs like actually
get caught in ribosomes--
PROFESSOR: There are a lot
of things that can be true.
And I would say that
in biology and in life,
what you do is you
first write down
the simplest possible model.
And then you go and
you make measurements.
And you ask whether the simplest
possible model can adequately
explain the data.
And if the answer
is no, then you're
allowed to start thinking
about other things.
Because everything's
is in principle true.
In that mRNA, maybe
it's this or that.
The question is whether
it's significant.
And at least from the
data from Sunney's group
would say that in that
condition, in those cells,
that those things
are not significant,
in the sense that you still
get a geometric distribution.
Of course it could also be that
those other things actually are
true and are significant.
But then you end up
with some new parameters
that describe how things look as
a result of all the complexity.
That's also OK in
the sense that I'd
say that you can get a
quantitative description
of the process by describing
it as a geometric with just
a single free parameter.
And they found that the mean
was four, or four or five.
The mean number of proteins
produced from each mRNA.
But they got this geometric
distribution in that paper.
Yes?
And I'll just mention
here that the mean of this
is rho divided by 1 minus rho.
So what you see is
that as rho goes to 1,
then this thing is
going to diverge.
And that makes sense.
because as rho goes to 1, it's
saying that you essentially
always synthesize another
protein rather than degrading.
And before I move
on, I just want
to say one more thing,
which is that there
are many different definitions
of the geometric distribution,
depending upon whether
the probability of rho
is the probability
of terminating,
or the probability of going
around, and also depending
on whether you're asking
what is the-- here
we're talking about
the probability
distribution for the number
of proteins produced.
Whereas we could have
talked about the probability
distribution for the number of
times we go around this loop
before, no, no sorry.
That is for the number
of proteins produced.
So the other way you could
have defined this is the number
of times where it's-- the number
of cycles that you had to go
before you went here, in the
sense that if you first go
here, you can either
call that a 0 or a 1.
Do you see what I'm saying?
And reasonable
people can disagree.
But you end up getting
distributions that are
just a little bit different.
So watch out.
If you just memorize
something, you
might have memorized
the equation
for a different definition
of this distribution.
Does everyone understand
what I tried to say there?
Maybe?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When
there's no degradation
is it still a Poisson?
PROFESSOR: Ah, if there's no
degradation then would this
be a Poisson?
I mean, this would
be infinity, right?
AUDIENCE: Right,
[INAUDIBLE] protein,
this is done independently,
like there's an mRNA.
[INAUDIBLE] proteins
independently.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I want to be clear.
This is, p of n is,
this is the probability
distribution for
number of proteins n,
produced from a single mRNA.
Now if there's no
degradation of the mRNA,
then this thing is
not even, I think,
defined in that the
number of proteins
produced from that mRNA just
really goes to infinity.
If you wanted to ask about
the probability distribution
for the number of
proteins produced
in some unit, some period
of time that would indeed
be a Poisson
distribution, assuming
that there's no degradation.
Do you understand what
I'm trying to say?
AUDIENCE: So Sp is like 0?
PROFESSOR: If Sp, I'm sorry.
If Sp were 0?
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
And you're saying that what
would be Poisson distributed?
AUDIENCE: The
number of proteins.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think
that actually-- no I
think that-- I think that
you're probably right.
That as Sp goes to 0-- I'm
a little bit worried that--
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
Zero-th order, sorry.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Not 0.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Right, so the mRNA distribution
we're about to find
is indeed going to be a
Poisson at steady state.
And so if there's some
process by which the protein
distribution is
really just mirroring
the mRNA distribution, then
it will also be Poisson.
Although I think you have to be
careful about how you actually
implement that.
Because even in the absence
of this geometric bursting,
different things, I
think, can happen.
Because for example, if there
were exactly 10 proteins
produced from each mRNA, then
that probability distribution
is a shift.
But then it's no
longer actually going
to be Poisson, because the mean
and variance are going to scale
differently if you do that.
Let's maybe do the Poisson
distribution for the mRNA
first.
And then we can try
to touch back on this.
So this is a plot of kind
of geometric distribution
with a mean of 3-4-ish.
Is everybody happy
with where we are now?
OK.
Now from this, what
we've said so far
is it obvious what the
distribution of proteins
will be in a cell?
We can say obvious, yes.
Or not obvious, no.
Ready, just verbal, yes?
Ready or no?
All right.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Right.
So we've said that
the distribution
of size of protein bursts
from single mRNA is geometric.
But that doesn't
mean that that's
going to be the distribution
of proteins in the cell.
And indeed after,
we're going to find
that the distribution of
mRNA is going to be Poisson.
But even then it's not
obvious what the distribution
of proteins is.
All right.
So what we want to
do now is we want
to introduce kind of a
simple version of what's
known as the Master Equation.
Now you guys are going to
do more reading on this
for the lecture on Tuesday.
Where we're going to talk about
the Master Equation, as well
as the Fokker-Planck
approximation.
Maybe the Gillespie
algorithm, and so forth.
But I want to start by
thinking about the this notion
in the simplest
possible context.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to think about the world.
So we want to know the steady
state, or the equilibrium
distribution of mRNA numbers in
the cell, given this process.
So that's great.
We can-- so mRNA
distribution, question mark.
Now in this case we don't
care about Sp, delta p,
because the only things that are
relevant are going to be these.
Now what we're
going to do is we're
going to think about the
world in which we just
defined states corresponding
to the different numbers
of these mRNAs.
So there's a state
where there's 0.
We can't go to the
left, less than 0,
but we can go to the state where
there's 1, or the state where
there's 2, and so forth.
Now the description
here is supposed
to be the analog
of this over there.
So this is trying to
understand the situation where
the deterministic equations
would be described
by m dot is equal to
this some synthesis rate,
minus a degradation rate that's
proportional to the number,
so minus delta m times m.
So what you can see is that
the deterministic equations
are very simple.
We already calculated
the equilibrium.
So when this thing
is equal to 0,
then we get that m
equilibrium is just
going to equal to the synthesis
rate divided by the degradation
rate.
If we're away from
the equilibrium
in this deterministic
approximation,
how long is it going
to take us to kind
of approach our equilibrium?
Verbal answer, ready?
Three, two, one.
[STUDENTS RESPOND]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's going to
be 1 over delta m.
So this tells us the
characteristic timescale
to come back.
So if we're-- this is the
equilibrium Sm over delta m.
This is m as a function of time.
If we're below, we come here.
If we're above, we come here.
And this time is 1 over delta m.
Are the any questions about?
Now this-- so I
want to highlight
that this is like the world's
simplest dynamical equation,
almost the world's simplest.
Yet what we're going to
find is that once we go over
and we try to understand
the full probability
distribution of the
stochastic system
then it's a little
bit more complicated.
In particular, we end
up with an infinite set
of differential equations.
So in general the
Master Equation format,
where we're going to write
differential equations for how
these probabilities
change over time.
Now what we've done is we've
traded a single differential
equation for an infinite number
of differential equations.
So that's a bummer.
But on the other
hand, it will allow
us to do the full
stochastic treatment.
And it's also a nice, to
me, the master equation
is useful in kind of two ways.
One is that it's going
to be a tool for us to do
analytic calculations.
But it's also kind
of a principled way
of organizing your thoughts
so that you can go and do
stochastic simulations, if
that's what you want to do.
So it's also just kind
of like a weigh station
to kind of help you
set up your simulation.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to ask about
the general way
that this thing is going to
move between different states.
In particular, we
are going to have
some general state in here.
Mn, which can go forward
or back, Mn plus 1.
Now what we want to do is think
about how those probabilities
are going to change over time.
So we typically have fn.
So this is often written
as an fn and fn minus 1.
And then this is a g.
I want to make sure I get
the n's and n minus ones
correct here.
Typically we write
gm plus 1, gn.
So these are telling
us about the rates
of being in this state,
with say, n mRNAs, as
compared to going here.
We're going here.
So then what we can
do is we can write
the change in the probability
of mn with respect to time.
Well there are just
a few different ways
that the probability can change.
So we can leave the state
in two different ways.
fn, gn.
So the way that we
lose the probability
is that we have fn plus
gn times the probability
that we are in mn.
That's an n there.
And then there are
going to be two ways
that we gain probability.
We can gain probably
from the mn minus 1.
So this is fn minus 1,
plus we can get probability
from the upper state.
That's a gn plus 1 mn plus 1.
So this is just saying that
the change in the probability
of being in this state is going
to be given by the probability
that we leave the state.
Sorry.
The probability that
we enter the state,
minus the probability
that we're leaving
the state, kind of the rates.
Now this is going to
be true for all n,
except for n equal to
zero, we don't have
the terms over on the left.
So this is kind of for all n.
So this is, in
particular this is for n,
basically 0 on up to infinity.
So this is a differential
equation for the probability
for having an mRNA.
But this is, we have to have a
different equation for each n,
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 on up.
So this is what I mean by
converting single differential
equation, which is actually an
exceedingly simple one, for one
that is for an infinite set.
And each one is even a
little bit more complicated.
In general, these f's and n's
can be pretty complicated.
In this situation
they're not so bad.
But let's make sure.
Can somebody say what
fn and gn are equal to?
Any volunteers?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right so fn, this
is rate that we add a new mRNA.
Well that's just
synthesis rate for mRNA.
And this guy is what?
AUDIENCE: Delta.
PROFESSOR: So this
is degradation rate.
And we actually do have to
multiply still by the number n.
And that's because as we go
further out here to the right,
then it is true.
The rate at which we come back
to the left is increasing.
Because there's just more
mRNA that can be degraded.
Now it's worth saying that
you can, for example, use
this to simulate the
probability distribution
if you start from any
distribution you like.
So for example, you could
start M0 equal to 1.
And then just simulate how
the probability recalibrates
and comes over here.
Similarly, you could
do it over here.
You could start with any
probability distribution
you want.
And you could use
this as a framework
to calculate what the
probability distribution will
be at any time later.
But you can also use
this just as a way
of figuring out what the
equilibrium distribution is
going to be.
Because at equilibrium,
we can just ask,
for each one of these
arrows, the probability
of moving to the right has to
be equal to the probability
of moving to the left, otherwise
we wouldn't be at equilibrium.
And that's true for every one of
these kinds of pairs of arrows.
And in particular,
what we can get,
and I want to make
sure that-- so but it's
not that fn is equal to gn--
so it's really going to end up
being that if you
see what fn and gn,
so that fn is going to have
to be equal to g of n plus 1
for all n.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you
also need to multiply
like natural probabilities--
PROFESSOR: Ah, Yes, yes, indeed.
So that sorry, times
mn times m of n plus 1.
So it's the kind of probably
flux so we have to equalize.
So this is nice because this
gives us a ratio of things.
In particular, this tells
us that the probability
of being in the n plus 1 divided
by the probability of being n,
and this is at equilibrium.
Is going to be fn
divided by gn plus 1.
Which is this synthesis rate.
And then down here is going
to be this degradation rate
times, in this case, n plus 1.
So this is useful.
Because for example,
if we start at m,
we could say that m1
over m0-- well maybe
we'll even put the
m0 over on the right.
So then m1, what
is that equal to?
That's going to be
synthesis rate divided
degradation rate, times m0.
But then we also know that m2,
well that's going to be again,
synthesis rate divided
by degradation rate.
And we're going
to get a squared.
But then now we have to
divide by 1/2 times m0.
Continuing on, m3 we get
Sm over delta m cubed,
divided by 1 over
3 times 2 times m0.
So in general, we
get the probability
of being in the nth state,
is going to be this thing.
We'll call it lambda for now.
Lambda to the n, divided
by n factorial, times m0.
Now what's the-- and
I'll-- remember lambda here
we've defined it to be
the ratio Sm over delta m.
Now if we sum over all
these probabilities,
what should we get?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: 1.
Right, if we sum over this
thing, what does that equal to?
It's what?
AUDIENCE: Eta lambda.
PROFESSOR: Eta lambda, right?
So just remember in this
world-- the sum over lambda
to the n, n factorial, from
n equal to 0 to infinity,
this is indeed the definition
of e to the lambda.
So what that means is that
the normalization condition is
that m0 has to be equal to e
to the minus lambda, which is
indeed a Poisson distribution.
I'll raise it up a little bit.
So this is saying,
OK, to back up.
If we just have constant rate
of creation of something,
constant rate of
degradation of that thing,
on a per item basis,
per unit basis,
then you end up getting
a Poisson distribution,
at equilibrium for the
number of that thing,
in this case, the number
of mRNA in the cell.
Questions about why that is?
What happened?
How we calculate it?
AUDIENCE: Could you
explain why [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
So this is basically f of n.
And this is basically
this g of n.
But remember here n is
the number of proteins
or the number of mRNA.
So then that's in the context
of the master equation,
then m and n are there.
You get n by the
current number of m.
Does that make sense?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm confused how
you changed m0 to the e
to the minus lambda.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well let's just do it.
So mn, this is the probability
that we observe n mRNA.
And we know that
the sum over mn,
so all these probabilities
from n equal to 0 to infinity,
has to be equal to 1.
Something has to happen.
Well let's do this sum.
This is equal to the
sum of lambda to the n,
over n factorial m0.
But m0, is this a function of n?
No.
m0 is just, this is just the
probability at equilibrium
that you have 0 mRNA.
So we can just pull
this thing out.
This is just some
number, some probability.
Now the statement is
that while this thing,
this is the definition
of e to the lambda.
So in general, so e to the x
we often write is equal to 1,
plus x, plus x squared
over 2, plus dot, dot, dot.
So this thing is indeed
just equal e to the lambda.
So what we know is
that this is still 1.
So m0 times e to the
lambda, is equal to 1,
so m0 is to the minus lambda.
Any other questions
about how we got here?
What's going on?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The plot
of the solution
to the adjoining
equation, that would
be like the mean
value, that would
be the behavior of
the mean values?
PROFESSOR: That Is
the expected behavior
of the mean value over time.
In this case, fn and gn
are both linear functions
of the number of the mRNA.
Which means that in the
context of the master equation,
if you ask about the
expectation of mn,
this quantity is indeed equal
to-- it has the same behavior
as, over time, as the
deterministic equations.
So if f and g are
nonlinear, then
actually you get a deviation.
But in this case, it
is indeed the same.
What it means that
if you compare
the stochastic and the
deterministic trajectories,
what you would see
is that this thing
is going to be a little
bit jagged, or whatnot.
And then even at
equilibrium it's
going to come up and
down a little bit.
I'm trying to add a
little bit of jaggedness
because it's discrete.
But the deterministic
equation here
is what you would get
if you average together
an infinite number of these
stochastic trajectories.
Because another one might
have come down here.
Does that answer?
AUDIENCE: Is m
playing a double role?
Like in that
deterministic equation,
m is the concentration of mRNA?
PROFESSOR: I think that I'm--
yeah I think that I should--
my nomenclature I think
was not very good.
I've used two different things.
And now that I'm
doing this, I think
that I should have-- I should
have just called it p of n,
or maybe I should've
used n here.
I think I was trying to
be consistent with some
of the previous, but I
think it was a mistake.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you
plotting stochastic?
PROFESSOR: I'm plotting--
OK, so no, I'm not.
So this is if you run an
actual stochastic trajectory.
Then at any moment
in time, you just
have one-- there's
some number of mRNA.
Whereas the sum
over the mn's, this
is talking about the
probability distribution
of the entire thing.
So really if you started here,
the master equation would give
you some distribution for the
n's, some distribution for m's.
And so if you looked
at these over time,
than the mean of
these distributions
is indeed equal to the
deterministic behavior.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
recover, like how would we
recover the differential
equation from the master
equation?
Is that possible?
Maybe that would help.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think that in the
end, there's going
to be a one-to-one
relationship from, I guess,
this differential equation
to the master equation.
I'm trying to think
of any weird case
or something funny's
going to happen.
Is something funny
going to happen?
AUDIENCE: No.
But like the easy way is just
to write them all in terms
of the distribution.
And you can just
differentiate the whole sum.
And in that sum, we
express the [INAUDIBLE]
with your last equation.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
But I think this is the
much more mathematical way.
I mean because I
think that actually, I
mean, from the
differential equation, you
actually from the terms
here, you can actually
construct the master equation.
And I think by the same way,
you can go from the master
equation, and I
think that there's
going to be a
unique differential
equation that would have gotten
you to that master equation.
So I think just from
the terms you can do it.
You could also do like
moment generating functions
to get to how things change.
But I mean I think that it's
really from this, for example,
I think it tells you that that
was the differential equation.
Does that--
I mean it's sort of--
the way that we typically
do things these things, is
that we have a differential
equation, and then we
construct the master equation.
So then we already knew what
the differential equation was.
But I think just from the
terms in your master equation,
you can say, all right.
This was the differential
equation that it started with.
Any other questions
about what happened here?
So we have, I think, a fair
number, a fair knowledge
of what's going on here now.
We know that the
equilibrium distribution
of mRNA in the cell is
going to be Poisson.
We also know that
the distribution
of the number of mRNA produced
per sell cycle is also Poisson.
But it's a different
Poisson from the first one.
We know that the number of
proteins produced per mRNA
is going to be
geometrically distributed.
The one thing that
we have not yet done
is to ask about the distribution
of protein in the cell.
So let's say
something about that.
I'm not going to do
the whole derivation.
Because it's harder.
But I encourage you to--
even the continuous version
of the derivation is
definitely harder than this.
But then the discrete
derivation is even worse.
So what we're going
to talk about,
and the way we'll
typically maybe
think about this from the
standpoint of this class
is the continuous
approximation to-- oh,
that might have ended
up being useful.
Well it's OK.
Is the continuous approximation
to the real answer.
And in particular, just the
way that the exponential is
the continuous approximation
of the geometric distribution,
in the same way you can
think about the equilibrium
distribution of
protein in the cell.
In this model is going
to be gamma distributed.
But gamma is a
continuous distribution.
But it's a continuous analog
of the negative binomial.
So let me just make sure I'm--
and Sunney Xie actually has
a nice PRL paper where he
derives the gamma distribution.
But even earlier
actually Paulson
had derived this negative
binomial distribution,
the discrete version
of the solution.
So this is the number
of protein per cell.
We already know the mean.
So this is approximately
distributed as a gamma.
A gamma is a distribution
that requires two parameters
to describe.
So a Poisson can be described
by single parameter.
Gamma is typically
described by two.
And b is going to
be the burst size,
whereas a is the mean number
of bursts per cell cycle, which
is the same as the
mean number of mRNA
produced, so mean
number of bursts.
So the gamma of this a, b.
All right.
So the gamma of a is
the gamma function.
It's equal to-- now is
it a minus 1 factorial?
I always get the-- is it a
minus 1 or a plus 1 factorial.
Anybody remember this?
Yeah, a minus 1.
I mean it's like
a lot of things.
You look at this equation.
It doesn't really
mean a whole lot.
But I think that a reasonable
way to think about this
is the gamma is
approximately what
you get when you add together
a different exponentials
with length scale, given by b.
When you add probability
distributions,
you have to do a convolution.
So in some ways, the
way to think about it,
and this kind of makes sense.
Because what is
happening is that it
takes something of
order cell division time
for these proteins to go away.
Because they're stable.
Now each-- and so then
what you want to know
is how many proteins
are kind of produced
over the course of a cell cycle.
Well that actually you can get
at by asking how many bursts
are there going to be.
And then how big are the bursts?
So indeed, the mean here
is equal to a times b.
And the variance is equal
to a times b squared.
So for example, if you
have a single exponential
distribution, with burst size
b, then this is what you get.
So this is the probability
that you get n proteins.
And this is this function of n.
So for a single burst, this
is exponentially distributed.
So this is the
continuous version.
Now if we add together
multiple of these bursts,
this is really saying that we
sample from this distribution,
say twice.
And then we add the
resulting value.
So this is a convolution.
You guys will have
an opportunity
to practice this on
your problem sets.
But what happens
is that you end up
getting something that looks
like-- it's going to go.
So it increases linearly.
If you added three
of them together
this increase is quadratic.
And it kind of goes like that.
So this thing
becomes kind of-- it
goes from a
distribution where it's
peaked at 0, to something that's
peaked at a nonzero value.
Now you can ask,
for example, what
happens as for a large a,
if you have many bursts,
what does this thing look like?
Oh, I wish I hadn't erased
my probability distributions.
So what are the gamma
converged to for large a?
A normal distribution.
Right?
So that's the central
limit theorem.
If you take any well-behaved
probability distribution,
you add it.
You sample from it many times.
Then you end up
getting a Gaussian.
If you don't remember
that very well,
then this is something to
read about over the weekend.
Just like the
Poisson is also going
to go to-- for large
lambda, the Poisson
also looks like a Gaussian.
Can somebody give
an explanation,
an intuitive explanation
for why that should be?
Why it-- yes?
AUDIENCE: Because in a
Poisson distribution,
you can't have
anything negative.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So a Poisson distribution
can't have anything--
but now I feel like
you're arguing against me.
Because a Gaussian has
negative values, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
So when the mean is really
small, only have [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
All right.
So what you're saying is
that Poisson for small lambda
it can't go negative.
OK.
No I think that that's true.
Yeah, and so somehow the
probability distribution
is somehow piling
up, as you say.
What are some other ways
of thinking about this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Because if you have a low lambda
that means it's a Poisson.
And then I'm just
imagining stretching out.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I think that's fair.
Another way we can
think about this,
is let's say that we
have some process that's
occurring randomly over
some period of time.
And this could be
say, mRNA production.
And here this is just the
number that we observe here,
this is going to be a Poisson,
with some mean lambda.
Now let's just say that I take
another one, same process,
same period of time.
How is this guy going
to be distributed?
So this also Poisson of lambda.
Now let's say I take this
probability distribution,
and I take this
probability distribution.
And I convolve them.
I'm going to do the
calculation of my head.
I did it.
So for those of you who haven't
done convolutions-- whatever.
Yes, what's the new
distribution going to be?
Poisson 2 lambda.
And why does that have to be?
AUDIENCE: That line was
sort of you put it by n.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's right.
This line, I just kind of
like I just made it up.
I could have just said, oh.
Well it's the same process
occurring over here.
So we have to have the mean.
It's still is going to
be a Poisson process.
And the mean has to
be the-- well we just
had twice the length.
And indeed, for independent
probability distributions,
means always add.
So this all consistent will
all the things we know.
So this has to be a
Poisson of 2 lambda.
If I add another
segment on here,
it has to Poisson of 3 lambda.
But what you see is that we see
that Poisson of n lambda, which
is the sum over many Poissons.
Poissons are well-behaved
probability distributions.
You add them
together, you're going
to have to get a Gaussian.
So you can see that the
Poisson has to become
Gaussian for large lambda.
And indeed it does.
So there's a comment
about this in the--
AUDIENCE: It's a little bit
more complicated than this
because obviously you
always just divide
from lambda [INAUDIBLE].
Like you would have to say
that Poisson lambda is just
like a combination of S--
PROFESSOR: OK.
You're saying that if I do
this calculation backwards,
I'm going to get into trouble.
Because if I try to break them--
AUDIENCE: So if you
require lambda to be-- you
have to have like a significant
probability of getting at least
one candidate, right?
PROFESSOR: So I'd say lambda has
to be much, much larger than 1.
So once you're at lambda of
100, it looks like a Gaussian.
And in Sunney's paper, he
had a comment about this.
Does anybody
remember what it was?
Was mRNA production
really well described
as-- they mention
that actually there
is some violation of
this model in the data.
AUDIENCE: Does it
go into eukaryotes?
PROFESSOR: Oh, as soon as
you go into eukaryotes,
this is why I stay
away from them.
But even in their
data, in E. coli,
they actually
observed a deviation.
So what they found is that there
was a cell cycle dependence
to this bursting rate,
i.e. the mRNA production
over the course
of the cell cycle.
And presumably their
conclusion of this
was that you have this guy.
And then he turns
into, gets longer.
And then eventually he septates,
and then you get two cells.
What he found is that these
longer cells had actually
a larger rate of mRNA synthesis
than the smaller cells.
And actually this makes sense.
Because here you maybe have
just one copy of the genome.
Whereas here you might have--
you're making a second copy.
So you might have two
copies of that gene.
So it may make sense that this
bursting rate should grow.
But does that mean
that you should not
expect it to be a Poisson
distribution for the number
of bursts per cell cycle?
No.
It actually is still-- it still
is described by a Poisson.
Because you can just say,
this is the cell cycle.
And here this is
Poisson of sum lambda 1.
Here is a Poisson
of sum lambda 2.
So there could be
a different rate
over the course of the thing.
But you still have
just two Poissons.
You still get another Poisson.
So adding Poissons,
gives you backup Poisson.
They don't have to have
the same mean lambda.
I just want to make
one comment about what
you have to do once you start
thinking about eukaryotes.
And the basic-- so you can
see the gamma distribution
can either be peaked at 0, or it
can be peaked at nonzero value.
So most, for like highly
expressed proteins,
you'll see that it looks
something like this.
Now for eukaryotes,
you also have
to consider there's
some rate that you
go between an active
and inactive promoter.
And this actually makes
things much more complicated.
So there's a rate
going to inactive,
a rate going to active.
And so now if you
look at, for example,
the mRNA number per
cell, you'll see
that it is no longer a Poisson.
And I encourage you, if you're
curious about such things,
to come up and look at this.
The solution for the
steady state distribution
has been solved analytically.
For example, Arjun Raj, who
is the author of the review
that you guys just read,
derived this equation here,
which I don't know
if you can see.
But even from a
distance, you can
see that this is the solution.
And this is just for
the mRNA distribution.
This is not even getting to
the level of the protein.
And it involves many gamma
functions, as well as
a confluent hypergeometric
function of the first kind,
which is a disaster.
But he went to Courant.
He was an applied mathematician.
So this is, I
guess, this is what
you can do after doing a
PhD in applied mathematics.
The point though is that it
ends up being very complicated.
And you can get hugely varying
distributions for the mRNA.
And indeed this is seen
in individual cells.
If you look at mammalian
cells, just at the mRNA level,
you can have some cells that
have hardly any mRNA, some
that have a huge number.
The protein
distributions actually
end up being more regular
than the mRNA distributions.
Because of this
difference in lifetime.
So the mRNA numbers
may fluctuate wildly.
But the protein numbers
will fluctuate less,
because they last longer.
So then you do some averaging
over this crazy mRNA business.
Now in the last--
yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: In terms of
timescale, like all
this is switching to the
active and inactive promoter,
like to the other--
PROFESSOR: Ah, yes.
That's a good question.
I think that people argue
very much about this.
This is kind of minutes.
This can be hours.
And this is maybe in
between those timescales
would be typical.
And when I say hours, especially
like in mammalian cells,
they might only divide
once a day or so.
So then this gets
to be many hours.
And then I'd say
minutes is kind of the--
So there were many
biological examples that
were discussed in that review.
And I'm not going to
talk about all them.
But I think that
it's a nice review.
Because it goes over some of
the papers that you've read,
or that we've talked about over
the course of the semester.
It also illustrates some
different biological context
in which noise may play a role.
But I want to mention
one study that
was done by actually
again, Arjun together
with Hedia Maamar, in
collaboration with Dave Dubnau,
where they were studying
this process of competence.
So in B. subtilis, during
sometimes particularly
of starvation, or other
forms of unhappiness,
they kind of pick
up DNA from outside.
So they'll import DNA.
Some of it may just be consumed.
But some of it could actually
be incorporated into the genome.
Now what they found is that
this competence process is
mediated by this protein comK.
And there was a
positive feedback loop,
where this guy ends up
positively activating itself.
And this helps lead to
bistability in this network.
Only a small
fraction of the cells
kind of get into this
high feedback state.
Only a small fraction of them
activate competence and then
uptake DNA.
And what they were able
to show in that study
was that it was sort
of noise-induced.
That they were able to
vary both the transcription
rate and the translation
rate, in a way
so as to reduce the noise.
The mean is the same.
So if you in the context of
this model, what they did
is they varied
transcription rate,
and they varied
translation rate,
each say, by a factor of 2.
So they got the same mean,
but then different noise.
And we're out of time.
I would have you vote.
But can anybody remember?
If you want to
decrease the noise
in the number of the
proteins, which of these
do you want to go up, and
which do you want to go down?
And which one is going up?
Which one's going up let's say?
AUDIENCE: Sm.
PROFESSOR: Sm.
Right, so if you want
to reduce the noise,
but keep the mean
constant, you increase
the rate of transcription,
and you decrease
the rate of translation.
Because the noise is really
driven by this protein
bursting behavior here.
And that's precisely
what they did.
They changed those
two quantities.
They got the same
mean, lower noise,
and then they reduced the amount
of competence in that sur--